INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to "Cloud OnAir," live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Indranil Chakraborty.
I'm the product manager
for Cloud IoT Core.
And we also have--
SAMRAT BAIRARIA: Hi.
My name is Samrat Bairaria.
I'm a technical program
manager at Google Cloud,
focusing on IoT Core.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
And what Samrat and I
will be talking about
is Google Cloud IoT
solution and Cloud IoT Core.
You can ask any questions
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
As a starting point, we need
to clarify what we mean by IoT.
The term is overloaded,
as you know.
But let's stop and
think about it a bit.
Imagine a city with
no congestion at all.
Can IoT do that?
Imagine an airport
with no delays.
Would IoT be able to play
a role in that as well?
Imagine the perfect energy
consumption every day
and every place.
How would IoT make that happen?
As in health care,
as well, can you
imagine medicine that would
be tailored with each person?
Again, can IoT help
with that as well?
Like we see with games,
but now with physical toys,
these are the cues for IoT,
connecting the physical world
to the cloud, and
being able to get
a comprehensive view of
an ecosystem embedded
with those fantastic outcomes.
IoT is all [INAUDIBLE].
Yes.
But the reality is
that IoT is everywhere,
and is the key to a better
outcome for everyone.
Now, it is estimated that 8.4
billion devices are connected
just in 2017, which
is more than 30%
higher as compared
to the previous year.
We are in a fast accelerating
part of an exponential curve.
A single jet engine from GE
generates about 500 gigabytes
of data per flight.
Two jet engine per plane
means 1 terabyte of data.
How many flights per day?
You see where I'm
going with this, right?
Pratt and Whitney's
geared turbofan
fitted with 5,000
sensors generate up
to 10 gigabytes of
data per second.
A single twin engine aircraft
with an average 12 hour flight
time could produce up to
844 terabytes of data.
To put it into
perspective, it was
estimated that
Facebook accumulated
around 600 terabytes of
data every day in 2014.
But with more than
7,000 engines,
Pratt and Whitney
could potentially
download zettabytes of
data once all the engines
are in the field.
Devices are much faster, and
they're constantly generating
a large amount of data.
And we are at a time
where we are generating
more data than ever before.
And not only are our devices
being connected and generating
an extremely large
volume of data,
it is happening virtually
in every industry.
If we look at manufacturing
or industrial,
we are seeing impacts to
every aspect of business,
from connected devices
on the shop floor,
to connected products
in the field.
From a paper machine,
you know that one--
and the one which makes
diapers, for example,
generates about 4 terabytes
of data per machine annually.
Or perhaps a gas
or a steam turbine
generates a ton of
data annually as well.
In fact, we have
partners who are already
delivering solutions
for manufacturing
built on the Google
Cloud Platform, which
we will talk about as well.
We are also seeing IoT
solutions in health care,
whether it is personalized
medicine or asset tracking
in hospital.
Someone like a company called
Dexcom, which continuously
monitors glucose
today, and are sending
10k compressed
[INAUDIBLE],, which
is expected to grow to about
1 terabyte of data per month.
This is compressed size.
The extracted data
will likely be
10x more than what it sends
from the glucose monitor.
If we look at the
transportation industry,
for example, we're seeing
significant changes
there as well.
We're seeing applications
in commercial vehicles,
to vehicles and the suppliers.
For example, we're seeing
the use of telematics
to improve customer
service by responding
to early signs of failure
in commercial vehicles,
and avoiding unexpected
breakdowns and towing.
This use of telematics
and maps are, again,
generating a ton of data,
which can be then processed
to get meaningful
insights from the field.
If we look at consumer
products industries,
we're seeing a
number of use cases
there as well for
marketing personalization.
But recently, we want to deal
with a large toy manufacturer,
focused on reinventing their
business driving innovation
and disruption.
So you get the point.
When you think about these
large volume billions of devices
connecting to cloud, or
through the internet,
it results in generating
a massive amount of data
from all these
devices, which are
much larger than what humans
have been generating so far.
So this is IoT data.
And Google has been
dealing with this kind
of data for a long time.
In fact, Google is one
of those companies which
has seven products which
has more than one billion
30 day active users.
And all of these
devices and users
are generating a ton
of data in petabytes
or in exabytes every day.
And what happens
when you collect
that massive scale of data?
Well, you become a
master of big data.
And you become a
data driven company.
This is our strength.
This is what Google brings to
customers that nobody else can.
Mastering big data
has some benefits.
We can use the data
to get key insights,
we can build machine learning
models, and so on and so forth.
It allows you to supercharge
innovation, and bring
new answers to hard problems.
We have been working
on this for a decade.
And we have used our
knowledge to help
our customers and our developers
in solving these big data
and machine learning
problems when you collect
this massive scale of data.
We have worked in
the energy sector
with our data
center optimization.
We have also worked in
many other fields as well.
When we are talking
about IoT, we
don't just focus
on one IoT product,
or a couple of IoT products.
We really want to
drive the conversation
to a business outcome
enabled by Google Cloud IoT--
analyzing big data
in stream or batch,
and then applying machine
learning capabilities.
It is together, Cloud
IoT as a solution,
and under the Cloud IoT
umbrella that customers
will be supercharged.
So what does it mean when
we say a Cloud IoT solution?
Well, as we started talking
to our customers, partners,
and developers, there were
three challenges which appeared.
And as Google, as
a company, we have
been dealing with these
challenges for a long time.
First is securely
connecting things.
Security applied to device
connectivity, and communication
and identity.
Nobody wants their
devices to be hacked.
And you've heard cases in the
past where this has happened.
And you know of
the consequences.
So how do you make sure that
all these devices, hundreds
of thousands,
millions or billions
of devices, which
are out in the field,
have the right
security patches, have
the right version
of their firmware,
and are very unlikely to
be hacked and compromised?
And how do you make sure that
all those devices can securely
connect to Google Cloud or
to other cloud platforms?
Second is scale.
We're talking about
unprecedented data.
As I just mentioned,
engines generate
gigabytes of data per day.
And so when you think
about that level of scale,
how do you make sure
that you can ingest
the data at scale from
millions of billions
of these connected devices?
And you can store all this
data in a cost effective way.
And you can analyze and process
it in a meaningful way as well.
And third is
actionable insights.
Once you have this data,
what do you do with it?
At the end of the day, why
does a customer need IoT if he
cannot get any
meaningful insights?
And this is, again,
where we have
been working with our
consumer products and a number
of products to understand,
to analyze data
to get really meaningful
insights which
we think we can share with
the audience at large.
So, as I mentioned,
we have been working
for a decade on large scale
infrastructure and machine
learning.
And we have built our IoT
stack on the same technology
and tools that we use at Google,
for Google Search, for at least
two billion Android devices that
connect to Google every day.
And we have an
end-to-end solution
to derive intelligence in the
moment with Google Cloud IoT.
Here is an
architecture of devices
that can connect to Google
Cloud via Cloud IoT Core, which
is a new service which
I will just mention.
And you can use our
downstream services,
such as Pub/Sub, Cloud Function,
DataFlow, Cloud BigQuery,
machine learning, and
other services for storage,
processing, analysis,
and using as machine
learning for predictive
insights as well.
The great thing about our
Google Cloud IoT solution
is that you can
seamlessly move IoT data
across Google services.
And you can decide which
services suit you best
for your business
use case, and then
use it for specific use cases.
You can ingest data
with Cloud IoT Core.
You can distribute data
with Cloud Pub/Sub,
apply data transformation
with Cloud DataFlow,
and then store data with Cloud
BigQuery, or big cloud storage,
or BigTable.
You can perform ad hoc
analysis with Google BigQuery,
visualize data using Cloud
Data Studio or Datalab,
and then derive intelligence
using cloud machine learning.
So let's start with IoT Core.
What is Cloud IoT Core?
So Cloud IoT Core
is a new service
which we announced last year.
And we just announced a general
availability of this service.
It's a fully
managed service that
allows you to easily and
securely connect your IoT
devices to Google Cloud, and
then manage and ingest data
from millions of
global [INAUDIBLE]..
And we think you would benefit
from this service as well.
So a couple of key
benefits of Cloud IoT Core.
As you know, Google is probably
the only non-ISP company
who has fiber optic
deployment across the Atlantic
and across the Pacific Ocean.
And we have a number
of points of presence
throughout the globe.
What this allows us to do is
to provide a single global end
point for your devices to
connect to Cloud IoT Core.
Whether your devices, or
your vehicle, or your asset
is in the US, or it's
somewhere in Asia, or somewhere
in Africa, you just
connect your device
to Google Cloud IoT Core.
And leveraging our global
networking infrastructure,
we will connect it to the
closest point of presence.
And from there, we'll connect
it to our closest data center.
So you don't have to worry about
picking which particular server
you need to connect to.
You just connect to one global
endpoint for Google Cloud IoT
Core.
And we take it from there.
Cloud IoT Core has
two key components.
One is what we call
Protocol Bridge.
And second is the
Device Manager.
What's great about
Protocol Bridge
is we realized that most
of the industrial devices
are using standard
protocols such as MQTT,
and even HTTP in many cases.
So with Cloud IoT Core, we have
native support for MQTT 3.1
and above.
And what's great
about this is, you
can connect your
devices without worrying
about instantiating a resource,
or an infrastructure, or a VM.
Whether you're
connecting one device,
or you're connecting 10,000,
or you're connecting millions
of devices as you get
ready for deployment,
you just connect your
device over MQTT or HTTP,
and we internally scale for you.
So we have automatic
load balancing
built in as part of Cloud
IoT Core managed service.
And since Cloud IoT Core
connects with and publishes
its data to Cloud
Pub/Sub, you can remotely
access all your device data
from a central location.
And you can monitor
all your devices
or your factories from a
central location that way.
The second component of Cloud
IoT Core is Device Manager.
And this is where we allow
users and developers to remotely
manage, control, and
monitor their devices.
So, first of all, we
really care about security.
And so we have a provision
to individually authenticate
each IoT devices.
We support asymmetry key
based authentication,
where the public key is
stored in with Cloud IoT Core,
and the private key is
stored with the device.
And we use the standard
[? jar ?] token
to sign with the private key.
And that's what we use for
individually authenticating
each device.
You can use our Device
Manager on Cloud IoT Core
to update configuration
of the devices,
and even control the devices.
You can, for example,
send firmware updates,
or new configuration,
or new settings
remotely from the
cloud to the device.
Your application just
needs to call an API.
And Cloud IoT Core makes
sure that those new settings
get propagated to all the
devices as they come online.
We also have added
row level access
to different groups of devices.
So, for example, you might want
to grant only View level access
to certain groups of users.
Or you might want to grant just
Add or Delete level access.
So there are a
variety of roles which
you can grant by using Cloud
IM on Google Cloud IoT Core.
And you might have heard
this term, digital twin.
And this is something which
is used a lot in the industry.
With Cloud IoT Core, it
essentially offers you
a digital twin, which is
a logical representation
of your device on
the Google Cloud.
We also have a rich set
of APIs and a UI console
for device deployment
and monitoring as well.
So this is, again, a
fully managed service
with a rich set of APIs
which allows you to securely
connect, manage, and ingest data
at scale from your IoT devices.
Recently we added a
new set of features
as well with our recent
beta and GA release.
You can bring your
own certificate
for additional security.
And our users can now
bring their own device key,
which is signed by the
certificate authority
for device authentication.
Logical device representation,
I just talked about,
which is essentially a digital
twin on Google Cloud IoT Core.
And we've also added
support for HTTP in addition
to MQTT as well.
Now, we understand
that many of you,
whether you're a developer, or
a device partner, or a customer,
before you go full
scale deployment,
you would want to build
some prototypes, some proof
of concept to
understand the ROI,
and to really understand
the impact of IoT.
So in our case, we have a
simple UI, User Interface,
for management of devices,
and monitoring those devices
as well.
So here's a screenshot of
our Google Cloud console,
where if you scroll
down on the left menu,
and you go to IoT
Core, you can start
sort of adding your devices, and
then monitoring them as well.
So it's a very simple UI which
can really get you started.
With IoT Core we have
a notion of registry,
which essentially is a
collection of devices
within a specific region.
So you can start by
creating a device registry.
And then the next step, once
you create a device registry--
for example, here
we have created
a registry called
Weather Station--
once you've created a registry,
you can add devices to it.
And as you add devices, you
would specify the public key
for authentication.
And there are a bunch
of other settings
which you can add to it as well.
Once you've added and
registered a device,
when the physical device
connects to Google Cloud IoT
Core, you would be able to see
the status of those devices
on the same UI console.
And with this UI
console you're also
able to not just monitor
the incoming data,
but you're also able to send
configuration or updates
to the device from
the UI as well.
So we've made sure that
we not only can't handle
a massive scale, but we also
have a simple UI for you
to get started quickly for
your initial proof of concept
or prototypes.
So once you've used Cloud
IoT Core for connecting
your devices in a secure
way, and then you manage them
at scale remotely, you can
use Pub/Sub for ingestion
and distribution of data.
The great thing about Pub/Sub
is that it has durable message
persistence, which means
Pub/Sub stores the data which is
published to it for seven days.
So what happens here is as the
devices connect to IoT Core,
and as they publish data, as
they start transmitting data,
IoT Core then publishes
data from all those devices
in a registry to
one Pub/Sub topic.
And Pub/Sub then keeps
the data for seven days.
So even if you lose
some connectivity,
you still have
persistence on that data.
And as Pub/Sub is
a global service,
you can use Pub/Sub
to remotely monitor
to have a central monitoring
system for all your globally
dispersed devices.
In addition, Pub/Sub
can be a great tool
for distributing data to
other downstream services,
such as Cloud Function,
DataFlow, or even
your own ETL pipeline.
So you can build a
simple business logic.
Let's take an example.
If you just want to monitor
the incoming temperature
data from your
temperature sensor,
and say every time it goes
above 80 degrees Fahrenheit
you want to turn on the fan.
What you can do here is you can
write a simple Cloud Function,
which subscribes to Pub/Sub.
And as it gets those
temperature readings
from the device that's
connected to Cloud IoT Core,
your logic will kick in.
And then you can send a
command back to Cloud IoT Core
to turn on the fan.
DataFlow can be used
for more complex event
processing, similar to how
you use Cloud Function.
And here you can have a window.
And you can say, I want to
compute the median temperature
over a 10 minute window
or a 10 second window.
This is great for complex
data processing as well.
And what Pub/Sub
allows you to do
is it allows you to
abstract and separate
your upstream devices from
your downstream application.
So you can continue
to make changes
on your downstream
application without meaning
to update the library or the
firmware of your devices.
So Cloud IoT Core in
conjunction with Pub/Sub
provides you a great
set of services
for securely connecting
your devices at scale,
ingesting data at scale, and
then distributing this data
to downstream services
for storage, processing,
and analysis.
So that was Cloud IoT Core and
how you can build a solution
with Google Cloud for IoT.
And now I'm going to hand
it off to Samrat, who
is going to give you a demo.
SAMRAT BAIRARIA:
Thank you, Indranil.
So for this demo which
we are about to show
you simulates an
asset tracking company
which can have multiple devices
or sensors around the globe.
I can do it.
We can just go back quickly.
So we wanted to
showcase how we can
build an end-to-end application
using Google Cloud IoT
Core and other Google
Cloud Services,
like DataFlow,
BigQuery, App Engine,
and visualize data on a
dashboard in real time.
I wanted to quickly go over
how the back end is set up.
IoT Core is designed
specifically
to securely connect,
manage, and ingest data
from globally dispersed devices.
We have set up Pub/Sub
topics and device registries
to connect the devices.
Once connected, they send
the telemetry data via MQTT
to the IoT Core endpoint.
As raw data is arriving
into Pub/Sub topics,
we then use DataFlow, which
subscribes to Pub/Sub topics,
set up earlier.
Cloud DataFlow is a
fully managed service
for transforming and
enriching data streaming in.
This could be real
time or batch data.
The DataFlow pipeline
then dumps the data
into BigQuery, which
is our data warehouse.
BigQuery also auto scales.
And set up is easy.
All we need to do is specify
our data schema to get started.
So from there, we also have
some Cloud Functions set up,
which also check the value of
the data against Cloud SQL.
If a certain
threshold is crossed,
we can then trigger the
Cloud Function routine
based on alert required.
Current threshold setups
are defined for weather,
temperature, and geofence.
We are also using Cloud Data
Store to store geofencing data.
And in the end, we're tying
all of this information using
App Engine.
In particular, App Engine Flex.
And we are also using Google
Maps API to visualize the data
points on the dashboard.
We are also calling
some shipping APIs
to know the shipping routes
a certain ship might take.
Now, switching over to the demo.
So as you can see here,
we have built a dashboard
where we can see all devices
and sensors a typical asset
tracking company might have.
We have the following
items on screen.
We have ships, which
are transferring goods
around the globe.
And then we have
large containers,
which are carrying goods from
dockyards into warehouses.
And then we have
trucks out here,
which are delivery trucks
which are transferring data
from the warehouses
to a customer,
or to a certain
asset on the ground.
One thing to note
here is, no matter
where the devices are
located in the world,
you need to not change which
endpoint the data is sent to.
So you can have
devices in the US,
in Australia, or even in China.
You, the developer, do not
need to specify an endpoint
where the data has to go.
Google front end will take
care of routing the packet
to the closest location.
Let's drill down a
little bit deeper
on what kind of information
the devices are sending us.
So in this case, we have a ship.
And the ships have a
bunch of sensors on them.
And if you can see, this is
a passenger fleet out here.
We have a passenger
fleet ship out here.
And we're calling
shipping APIs to see
what is the flag of the ship?
And then we have a bunch of
sensors on the ship itself,
which is streaming
data using IoT Core.
We can see temperature readings.
We can see the course
the ship is taking,
as well as the wind speed
the ship is encountering.
All this information
is being streamed
through IoT Core in real time.
And we can visualize
this information
on the dashboard
running our App Engine.
Let's take another example here
of a truck which is en route
or which is on a delivery
route to a customer.
So for this truck,
again, we have a bunch
of sensors on this truck as
it's traveling from point A
to point B. We want to track,
what is the equipment status?
Is it full, or has
data been unloaded?
We want to make sure
of the door status.
This is for security purposes to
see if someone opened the cargo
door during transit.
We also have ambient temperature
within the cargo hold.
And we also have the
device battery levels
for each device
that is on board.
As the truck is making its
journey across from point A
to point B, it's streaming
data to us in real time.
And we can visualize
this on screen.
We can also interact with
the devices on these trucks.
For example, we want
to set the threshold
of what is the perfect
temperature the cargo
hold should have.
So let's say in this case--
let's take it a little extreme.
Let's take it we want it
to be one degree Celsius.
Once you set that, the IoT Core
communicates back to the device
and tells it, this
is a new threshold
it needs to act against.
We also use Cloud
Functions in the back end
to trigger if certain
thresholds are crossed.
So if you can see on screen, as
the threshold has been crossed,
it is having a alerts
generated on screen.
You can also see the
history of all the data
that this device
has been streaming.
All this information is
stored into BigQuery.
We are passing the data from
the device, to IoT Core,
to DataFlow, and
then to BigQuery.
And then we are acquiring
it using the App Engine
application.
You can also interact with other
APIs like the Google Maps API,
and then make this whole
internal application work.
Let's take an example
out here where
we want to separate a geofence.
And if a device
crosses the geofence
we want some kind of an alert.
As you see, if the device is
not in a particular geofence,
we have a notification
on screen.
So we wanted to show the
robustness of IoT Core,
and how it interacts
with the various
of the subsystems
underneath, and how fast
this whole application works.
You can also see
historical alerts
that the devices have been
generating and sending it
through IoT Core.
So like Indranil
said earlier, it
doesn't matter if you have a few
hundred devices, or thousands
or devices, or a
million devices.
We scale automatically for you.
You can seamlessly interact
with other Google products,
like Google Maps API, and data
store, based on data streaming,
into IoT Core.
Hopefully this
small demo was able
to demonstrate the
robustness of IoT Core,
and how you can use it for
your own business logic,
or for your own
personal projects.
Thank you for your time,
and over to you, Indranil.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Thank you, Samrat.
Let's go back to the slides.
So, as Samrat gave you a
demo of asset tracking--
and what was great
in this demo was
you could see real time
the movement of the assets.
And whether it's in the US
or a different location,
we can still provide the
same real time tracking
regardless of the location.
And it uses IoT
Core Google Geo APIs
and a bunch of other
services where all of this
comes together for
a complete solution.
So the point I want
to make here is,
Google Cloud IoT is really a
platform for end-to-end IoT
data processing.
So for ingestions,
connection, and management
of your IoT device data, we
have IoT Core Cloud Pub/Sub.
We also have Android
Things, which I'm
going to talk about in a bit.
For processing, cleaning,
and storing, in a cost
effective way for this
massive amount of data,
we have DataFlow function, Cloud
Functions, BigTable, Spanner,
and even GCS.
And, finally, to analyze
and visualize, and then
predict outcomes, we have
BigQuery, Cloud Datalab,
Machine Learning
Engine, Data Studio.
And you can even use Cloud
Functions and DataFlow.
So Google Cloud
really has all the set
of services which you need to
build an end-to-end solution,
and build some
compelling applications,
just the way Samrat
just showed you
about real time asset tracking.
I want to touch upon
Android Things, which
is our version of an operating
system for the IoT devices.
Android Things essentially
is Android for IoT.
And whats great
about Android Things
is it gives you
three key benefits.
One is, since it's built on
Android, it's highly secure.
It's a secured boot
operating system.
And if you have a
gateway or a device which
runs Android Things, it's
very hard for that device
to be compromised.
Second is it's fully
managed by Google.
When you have millions
or billions of IoT
devices globally
dispersed, you want
to make sure that all those
devices have the right firmware
version, have the
right security patches,
and have the same version
across all the devices.
And just the way we do it
with our Android mobile phones
and Chromebooks,
Android Things also
ensures that all
your fleet of devices
will have the same version of
operating system and security
patches as well.
So that's great for a
large enterprise, and even
a medium sized
enterprise customer.
And finally,
Android Things comes
with support for some
of our Google services,
such as TensorFlow
and machine learning.
So you can imagine if
you have a camera which
runs Android Things and you have
a cloud machine learning model,
or a TensorFlow
model to detect faces
of employees of your company,
training of the model
can happen in cloud.
The inference can still
happen locally on the camera,
using Android Things
and its set of APIs.
So it really makes it
easy for you to build
compelling applications.
And the benefit of Android
Things, the related benefit
is since it's Android,
you are tapping
into the Android application
developer ecosystem as well.
So it's really easy to build
edge applications for edge
compute as well.
So with Android Things,
it's secure manageability,
secure boot, and APIs
for machine learning.
And it works seamlessly
with Google Cloud IoT Core.
We believe we have a
pretty compelling solution
for not just on
the cloud aspect,
but also on the
device aspect so you
can build an end-to-end solution
for your business specific use
cases.
We also understand that
in order for our platform
to be more sort of
useful, we can't just
do everything on our own.
So we've been working hard to
build our partner ecosystem,
both on the device side, as
well as on the application side.
So we have a number
of device partners,
such as Intel, Wireless,
NXP, Arm, Marvell.
There are a large number
of device partners
who have IoT devices
which work seamlessly
with Google Cloud IoT Core.
So if you're using any
of our partner devices,
it'll work seamlessly with
Google Cloud IoT Core.
We also have a number of
SIs and application partners
as part of the
ecosystem who can help
you build your specific
application for your IoT use
cases, companies such as
Mnubo, Agosto, Losant, SOTEC.
All of these
partners can help you
build specific IoT
applications using Google Cloud
Platform and Cloud IoT Core.
So we are very, very excited
about our growing partner
ecosystem.
And this is just a snapshot.
We have a lot more on
the website as well.
So why Cloud IoT?
And I think I just want to
summarize the reason why
we think you, as a
developer, as a partner,
or as a customer should use
Google Cloud IoT for your IoT
application.
One, Cloud IoT Core lets
developers and enterprise
easily connect your millions
of devices, which are globally
dispersed, through
the protocol endpoint,
against a global endpoint,
with less hassle,
and no worries about scale.
We take care of
automatic scaling.
And that's great for
applications and developers
so that you can focus on
your business application
and not worry about the
underlying infrastructure.
Second is, as part of
Google Cloud IoT platform,
you're not just collecting
your device data,
but connecting your
global device network
on intelligent cloud.
Google Cloud machine learning
and big data innovations
helps you to make
sense of the IoT data.
You can perform ad hoc analysis,
as I mentioned, with BigQuery.
You can visualize
data with Data Studio.
And you can derive meaningful,
intelligent insights
using Cloud Machine Learning.
And third is, Cloud IoT Core
is a service architecture.
It's a fully managed service.
So you don't have to instantiate
a separate instance of Cloud
IoT Core.
You will just connect your
devices to Cloud IoT Core,
and off you go with
your application.
So whether you start
with few devices
as you embark on your journey
with the proof of concept,
to when you're
ready for deployment
and you want to deploy millions,
or hundreds of thousands,
or billions of devices,
it's the same application.
It's the same service
which you just
connected to without
worrying about
the underlying infrastructure.
Fourth is, given
our global network,
we can really offer
minimal latency.
And especially in the case
of IoT, every millisecond,
every second matters.
And latency is critical.
And Google ensures
that your devices
are delivered with the
lowest latency using
our global networking
infrastructure.
The highest quality
of private networks
that connects our regional
locations and data
centers to more than
100 global network
points of presence close to
your device and your users.
This means that the
device will always
connect to the closest
point of presence
and benefit from our
global network backbone
with the lowest latency.
And finally, Cloud
IoT core works
seamlessly with millions
of Android Things
devices, and devices from
leading hardware makers,
manufacturers, such as Intel,
NXP, Microchip, Marvell, Sierra
Wireless, and others.
And the Android Things
device operating system
is updated and passed by Google.
As data is generated
in the sensor,
it seamlessly moves into
Google Cloud for processing,
analyzing, and integration.
So that was an
overview and a demo
for building IoT
solutions on Google Cloud.
Thank you for your time.
And stay tuned for live Q&A.
We will be back in less than a
minute.
Thank you everyone
for the questions
that we received
from the audience.
Samrat and I are going to
walk you through and try
to answer as many as we can.
So let's get started.
So the first
question we had was,
what are some of the
advantages of MQTT over HTTP?
So there are a
couple of advantages.
First of all, what we find
is that in the industry,
many of the devices
are already using MQTT.
And MQTT, as you know, is
a relatively new format
which was introduced
in, I think,
towards the end of the 1990s.
The key benefits are, with
MQTT, it's built over TCP.
So you can use TLS and achieve
the same level of security
as you do with HTTP.
In addition, with
MQTT, the payload size,
the bandwidth consumption
is much lower.
You can send binary
data over MQTT.
And that saves you
a lot in bandwidth.
So that is one of
the key reasons why
many of those devices use MQTT.
SAMRAT BAIRARIA: And you
don't need much storage space
with MQTT.
So you can have a smaller
footprint for a device.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
That's right.
You don't need
much storage space.
And then second is MQTT has this
topic structure which really
works well for devices,
as devices publish data
on a particular
topic, and you have
applications subscribing to
those topics to collect data.
And you can also use it for
device to device communication
as well.
So I think those are the two
key benefits of MQTT over HTTP.
SAMRAT BAIRARIA: [INAUDIBLE].
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Second question.
What formats are
supported for payload?
So the way we look
at IoT Core is,
we've taken a set of
data agnostic and format
agnostic approach.
At the same time,
our recommendation
is, you can use
JSON as a format.
You can also use Protobuf.
If bandwidth is
critical for you,
and you want to
save every bit, you
can use Protobuf as well
to send binary data.
Third question is, do
I have to create keys
for devices on the cloud?
You want to take that?
SAMRAT BAIRARIA: Yeah.
Well, you can use keys, or
you can also use certificates.
We have a bring your own
certificate mechanism
where you can generate
your own certificate.
Give us the public
certificate on IoT Core.
And you can have
your device assigned
with your private certificate.
So you can choose whatever
path you want to take.
You can create your
keys on Cloud IoT Core.
You can do it using Open
SSL on your machine.
Or you can get your
own certificates.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Yeah.
And I think, if I
understand it right,
you really want to create
virtual devices on cloud
for the purpose of testing.
And the short answer is, yes.
Even if you are
creating virtual devices
to connect to
Cloud IoT Core, you
have to use private
keys and public keys,
a private-public key combination
to connect to Cloud IoT Core.
Otherwise it will
reject connection.
And on our website, there
are very clear instructions
and samples which will
help you to generate keys,
whether it's for
a virtual device,
or even for a physical device.
Then the final question is, how
can I use multiple MQTT topics?
So there are two ways to
address this question.
One is, if you're trying to use
multiple topics on the device
side, today we said we had
two parent level topics.
So one for sending telemetry,
which are telemetry events,
and one for the device
to publish its own state
information.
And for telemetry, the
topic is slash events.
Devices slash device
ID, slash events.
But you can create subfolders.
So if you want to
send temperature
on a separate topic,
you can say slash event,
slash temperature, or slash
event, slash pressure.
And interesting enough, just
now in our GA release we also
have a new feature
which will allow you to
map these different MQTT
topics to a different Pub/Sub
topic on Google Cloud.
So you can map the temperature
topic to temperature Pub/Sub,
to [INAUDIBLE] the topic,
and then so on and so forth.
So you can really
use multiple topics,
both on the device side, as
well as on the cloud side.
Great.
So thanks everyone,
again, for the time.
And hopefully this was useful.
And we love to
hear your feedback.
Stay tuned for the next session,
End-to-End Machine Learning
with TensorFlow on the
Google Cloud Platform,
live from our Kirkland office.
And thanks again.
SAMRAT BAIRARIA:
Thank you everyone.